c'est le dernier véhicule blindé
innovante du groupe arcus le cheikh pas
à 2m a été conçu au sein du bureau
d'études implanté sur le plateau de
satory à versailles un co-développement
avec deux autres entreprises thales et
le groupe espagnol ntg s on arrive un
véhicule qui est rapide mobile bien
protégé avec un système qui se déploie
automatiquement à l'arrière du véhicule
donc sans intervention humaine le
pointage se fait aux nerfs automatique
également par le chef de bord à
l'intérieur l'idée de base du véhicule
c'est d'arriver rapidement sur une
position proche de l'ennemi on est sur
une portée de 8 à 13 km un peu plus il y
en a pas des munitions guidées laser de
tirer sur l'adversaire est en fait
d'être parti avant même que l'adversaire
commence à utiliser des moyens de
contrer batterie c'est à dire de
détection du départ du tir leader
européen des véhicules blindés arcus
emploie 600 personnes dans le
département des yvelines
du côté de saint germain en laye
l'entreprise x blue est spécialisée dans
les technologies de pointe au début
engagés dans le civil elle a orienté son
activité dans la défense navale puis
terrestre x blue développe notamment un
gyroscope à fibre optique destinée aux
blindés s'agissant par exemple de la
défense on va avoir des applications qui
sont de l'ordre de la navigation et du
pointage donc la navigation cela
signifie concrètement qu'on va pouvoir
obtenir la position en temps réel un
véhicule sans avoir recours à des
signaux extérieurs tels que le gps ou
galileo pour l'europe et autres c'est
tout l'avantagé d'avoir une navigation
inertielle c'est qu'on va pouvoir se
priver totalement de signes à
l'extérieur donc pour les forces ça
présente un avantage majeur étant donné
que on le voit avec le contexte actuel
les menaces de brouillage et de l'orage
de ces signaux extérieurs sont présents
et
et pour avoir des conséquences
dramatiques pour l'opération dans le
sens où un véhicule pourrait se
retrouver perdu en plein milieu champ de
bataille dans les yvelines le secteur de
la défense emploie plus de 11 mille
personnes c'est le premier département
d'ile-de-france dans cette activité en
termes d'emploi